so even though the prior president
donald trump was one of the most
authoritarian leaning dictator wannabe
presidents that we've had
in the modern political era
there are people on the right and this
includes republican elected officials
and this includes some people in
right-wing media who want you to believe
that it is joe biden who is about to
imprison people
force people to do this or to do that
regulate people into oblivion things
that joe biden has actually shown no
interest in doing
and one such example of this came to us
from fox news a couple days ago
where geraldo rivera was hosting um
something on on fox news and he
interviewed fox and friends uh i guess
weekend host will kane will kane is not
like part of the big three hosts of the
weekday fox and friends but i guess he
must be a weekend guy or a fill-in guy
and will kane showed up and said that
soon
americans who were not vaccinated
against covet 19 are going to be put in
camp sort of like concentration camps
fema camps remember fema camps when
barack obama was president was a big
thing
and this was all part of being against
masks and being against vaccines and all
of these other things so let's listen to
this together and see if there's any
evidence presented actually welcome back
as covid cases rage in several locations
across the country the cdc telling
unvaccinated people not to travel over
this labor day weekend with cnn's don
lemon going even further pointing this
scolding message to those who still
refuse to get the shot
some people who are so selfish are
saying it's my freedom and i don't want
to get vaccinated i want to do that okay
fine but think about someone other than
yourself and if you don't believe that
covet is real and that can it can affect
your health and possibly take your life
don't go to the hospital then
when you get sick
don't go to the hospital if you get sick
that's a little harsh digging but
isn't it isn't it logical a little to
say that uh you know vaccination plus
mask equals travel
unvaccinated uh you know
isn't it prudent they don't even know
what they're talking about for
unvaccinated people not to travel
i would if i wasn't vaccinated i think
this is a personal choice if i wasn't
vaccinated then i well i'm a hermit i
might just stay i might stay at home but
that is a personal choice unvaccinate
people to vaccinate people if you got
the shot you should be fine but i want
to explain really great medical analysis
here expose and and i'm actually not
going to steal this from greg because i
know greg has talked about this before
but this exposes the combination of like
dumbassery and cruelty by don lemon
because i is he he's literally saying if
you smoked and you get lung cancer you
don't get any treatment if you didn't
wear if you didn't wear sunscreen you
have melanoma you don't get cancer
treatment you ate too many cheeseburgers
no open heart surgery if you use so
that's
again he's too stupid to be on tv but
he's perfect for cnn
but there's two things going on here
will and i know how deeply you feel
about this yeah there's the
premise that unvaccinated people should
not travel
because of the risk the exponential risk
they pose to people
or children for example uh and the other
thing is the cruelty of the the you know
the cavalier uh well don't go to the
hospital then if you if you were that
arrogant everybody sort of seems
confused on this segment if you can't
tell fascinated but in terms of the
first the you know the cdc is advising
people
if you unvaccinate don't travel so let
me work that backwards um regarding the
second point you made whether or not
it's cruel daigon's exactly right we're
veering dangerously close to
exterminationist language what
wide extermination
otherwise examinations absolutely that's
the that's the next step putting putting
the unvaccinated into someplace else
camps whatever it may be when you listen
to the cruelty of don lemon what is will
talking about the the unvaccinated are
more likely to end up dead in the morgue
from covid than they are to end up in
some kind of camp for the unvaccinated
this reminds me of you know like in high
school
in college
there there was always some
kind of know-it-all
who would have an epiphany of some kind
and they would they would rant
and nobody really wants to argue with
them so you just kind of go hmm
okay all right moving on
um that camps and exterminationism
that's what will kane is uh making me
think of here
and remember that the predictions that
they're gonna end up in camps
have been going on for a long time when
democrats have been president remember
under obama there were going to be fema
camps and people were going to be sent
to fema camps re-education camps et
cetera it didn't happen it's just par
for the course when a democrat is in the
white house now meanwhile tucker carlson
uh claims that the left just wants to
kill unvaccinated people and his guest
uh teddy daniels
who's a former officer
pro-trump military veteran running for
something i think
uh agrees here is the left wants to kill
the unvaccinated no the vaccines are
supposed to save people guys yeah this
is still america tucker okay if
if you want to wear a mask wear a mask
yeah if
if i if you don't want to wear a mask
don't wear a mask that's what makes this
country great with the vaccines
if you've had that conversation with
your doctor and you feel a vaccine is
the best route for you
go for it
cool
but for those that don't
that's also cool
you know let people live their lives
wait but shouldn't we kill people who
don't get the vaccine well that's what
the left wants to do yeah i've noticed
you know
what
what
do people watch this stuff and believe
it i think to some degree they must
the left wants to
put into camps the unvaccinated the left
wants to kill the unvaccinated and the
problem is
that this stuff has worked to weaponize
disinformation
anti-science beliefs
in a way that is preventing us from
actually dealing with the pandemic the
way we could delta has been a problem
essentially everywhere but there are
countries that have dealt with it far
better
countries that have higher vaccination
rates countries where people are
actually following the medical
guidelines and they have turned it not
just into medical guidelines they have
turned it into a political battle that
they assess to be life and death along
the wrong lines it is in a sense life
life or death right i mean we we know
that your likelihood of getting really
sick from covet is way lower if you're
vaccinated we know that your likelihood
of dying from covet is way lower if
you're vaccinated it is life or death
but they've got a completely different
life or death sort of battle line drawn
um and it's unfortunately worked really
really well at convincing a lot of
different people if you ever feel like
you just don't have enough time to read
all the books you want to read you have
to check out one of my favorite apps
called blinkist blinkist takes thousands
of popular nonfiction books and distills
each one down into an e-book or
audiobook that you can get through in
just 15 minutes where you're getting all
the key takeaways from the book just
imagine how you'll be able to expand
your horizons and knowledge by being
able to soak up all of the important
insights from ten different books in an
afternoon obviously it's perfect for
exposing yourself to a new book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for or you
can use it to revisit a book you've
already read
or use it to preview a book before you
buy the full version and read it i
recently read a brief history of time of
course by the great stephen hawking this
is a book that i have been aware of for
so long and other things got in the way
and it was fantastic to check it out on
blinkist blinkist has books on politics
philosophy science they have 27
different non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get
twenty five percent off a subscription
when you go to blinkist.com slash pacman
i've put the link right underneath this
video